so nurses walked out yesterday there's
another strike next week in England
Wales and Northern Ireland you're an a e
doctor do you support what the nurses
are doing yes yes I do
um well nurses and healthcare workers so
more broadly have seen their pay been
eroded over the past decade or so and
over the past year it's just fallen off
a cliff and so that balance between
how difficult the job is which has
become more difficult over the past few
years and sort of what you're enumerated
for as a result of it that mismatch has
just grown and that's what's led to
these strikes we've seen we're seeing
sort of record levels of quit rates
among nurses as well so that's one
option but for the people who want to
continue to be a nurse they're using
pretty much only voice mechanism they've
got left they've tried other ways the
government hasn't listened and so now
it's about industrial action and a hope
would be that someone will finally
respond to what they are saying and and
you're not part of the dispute as a
doctor but what's your reaction when you
hear the government say we can't afford
a 19 pay rise there just isn't the money
there and we're also we're following the
advice of the independent pay review
board what do you make of that argument
well I mean the government has a pretty
simple question it should be asking
itself which is
is pay in the health service at a level
that can maintain services at the level
I want them to be at the level I'm
promising right and the answer that
quite plainly is is no so you have two
options the first option for the
government is to come and to sit at the
negotiating table and to revise their
payoffer to set pay at a level that
fills jobs to set pay at that level that
ensures NHS performs at a standard that
we all expect it to that the government
wants it to the second option for the
government is actually to come out and
to talk to voters and to tell the public
that actually public services are going
to deteriorate they're going to
deteriorate further and that we need to
get used to that there's a new normal
and that Baseline of what we expect from
the Health Service is now lower those
are the two options for the government
what they're doing right now which is
letting inflation erode wages but still
saying Services can be maintained that
just from an economic perspective is
plainly dishonest okay and they argue
that they're putting lots of money into
the NHS don't they if the isn't a
resolution do you expect to see more
strikes to come the RCN it is saying
that that is the case if there aren't
negotiations and there isn't progress we
can expect more after these the ones
next week I think that's right I think
there will be more strikes if the
government continues with its line I
suspect those strikes that come in
January will be more severe and more
coordinated and will lead to Greater
disruptions so I think I mean the offer
the RCN has made to the government which
is if you sit at the table we will
suspend the strikes that feels I think
to most people like a pretty reasonable
offer to have made but if the government
continues to say no we're saying
Hardball then I suspect the strikes to
come will be more disruptive what about
patient safety do you have concerns you
work in a e yourself I know you haven't
worked this week so you can't comment on
what effect the strike had yesterday but
do you have worries that during strikes
Emergency Care is compromised
right I mean there's there's sort of two
ways to think about how the strikes
affect patient care there's what it
means for patients in the immediate term
what it meant for patients yesterday
what it will mean for patients next
Tuesday next Wednesday and then there's
what it means for patients over the
coming months and years so let's take
each of those in turn what does it mean
for patients in the immediate term have
Services being disrupted yes that's
almost how the strike works that's the
voice mechanism the disruption to the
normal running of healthcare services is
the voice mechanism here they've been
organized in a way to minimize
disruption to sort of critical services
so most the disruptions have happened to
outpatient services to planned care to
non-emergency operations
um and sort of certain services like
children's emergency services are being
staffed at normal levels a e services
are being staffed at bank holiday level
so basically it's it's an effort to
mitigate the harms that would come
around to patients as a result of
disruptions but disruptions are
happening access to care is being
disrupted the key thing to remember here
I think is the counterfactual so
if this industrial action wasn't
happening do we have a Health Service
where Safe And Timely access to care is
the reality and quite plainly the answer
to that is is no right and that leads me
on to the second point I want to make
what's the impact of these strikes for
patients in the medium in the long term
which is if the industrial action is
successful in negotiating a better pay
offer for the nurses and for healthcare
workers well then that will lead to a
larger more satisfying more productive
Workforce which in turn will lead to
better quality care and better access to
care for patients so in the long run
this could be in patients interest and
certainly that's what nurses are arguing
of course and yet people who are in an
emergency situation are not going to be
thinking about the long term I think am
I going to get my care now and there are
warnings that next week's ambulance
strike could actually be even more
compromising as far as patient safety is
concerned do you have that worry I do
yeah
um I think the the the ambulance worker
strikes on Wednesday poses a different
sort of risk to patients and it's quite
hard to see how that plays out again
they are being planned in a way to try
and mitigate the harms that would come
around ideally that no one would become
severely unwell as a result of not being
able to access care right so that
conversations are going on between
unions and between providers to ensure
that can happen it's hard to see how it
plays out and what the unions will argue
and what healthcare workers are arguing
is that the Bull's still very much in
the government's court and they could
sit down at the table and suspend these
trucks